You can catch a disease if it's contagious,
but surprisingly, you can catch a behavior
too.
Suicides, homicides and mass shootings are
ALSO contagious…
😬
We're all familiar with the idea that the
flu is contagious.
I sneeze on you, you get the virus, and you
get sick.
But behaviors can also be contagious, and
for a number of reasons.
Yawning is agreat example.
Simply SAYING yawn can trigger yawning -- did
you yawn yet?
*YAWN* That's a contagious behavior, if an
innocuous one.
Scientists THINK it has to do with the empathy,
the understanding and sharing the feelings
of another, but after a major study in 2014
they're still scratching their heads.
Speaking of scratching, me talking about itches
might make you itch… do you have one?
Itching behavior is ALSO contagious, and so
is laughter; especially when things are awkward!
Laugh tracks are Hollywood's way of triggering
that empathetic humor response!
In one study, researchers from the University
of Hawaii showed videos of people describing
a positive or negative memory and when showing
that video they found people FELT more akin
to the nonverbal emotion the person was feeling,
not the things they were saying.
Basically, if you feel emotion when talking
to a person, it's possible the person is feeling
the same emotion!
Our brain's contain mirror neurons which are
specifically for mimicking the behavior of
our social peers.
When people watch sports and see a player
throw the ball, their brain sends signals
to their arm that mimic that movement; it's
both psychological AND physiological.
Unfortunately, this can go well beyond sports
or movies.
Research on "suicide contagion" is as old
as recorded history.
As much as five percent of all suicides may
be a result of contagious behavior.
When suicides happen in school, or when celebrities
commit suicide, suicide clusters begin usually
in teens and young adults.
Gladwell wrote extensively about contagious
behavior in his book, The Tipping Point.
We're social animals, so when we see behavior
happening, we emulate it; physiologically,
emotionally and, apparently, violently.
Since 1991, the rates of murder, robbery,
rape, assault are all down…
In fact, these crimes are lower today than
at any time in the last 50 years.
The number of mass shootings, however, has
sharply increased since 2000 according to
the FBI.
There are now an average of around 16 mass
shootings a year in the U.S.; or perhaps as
many as one every 12.5 days depending how
you count them.
Using this data, a paper in PlosONE found
on average, one school shooting inspires point-22
more school shootings; and a mass shooting
inspires point-3 more mass shootings peaking
every 13 days.
Mathematically, if you have 4 mass shootings
in a short period, chances are one of those
was inspired by one of the others.
When shootings include more than three people,
it was more sensational, had increased media
coverage, and could then be considered a contagious
behavior.
Combating the negativity of contagious behavior
may be as simple as holding each other accountable
for our actions before we get there- Being
open, clear and honest about the negative
effects.
For example, after Kurt Cobain's suicide in
1991 the media focused on the effect on his
surviving family, and the sadness of his friends
and fans -- LOWERING the suicide rate.
This was shocking, but made sense.
A positive behavioral contagion beat the negative
one.
Health researchers have long studied peers
positive motivation being contagious in exercise
and healthy habits.
Perhaps these darker behaviors are susceptible
as well.
There hasn't been a ton of research on gun
violence in the U.S., in part because Congress
banned federal funding for gun violence research
in 1997; that ban remains in place today,
however, if more research can uncover HOW
violent behavior like suicide and mass killing
is contagious; the implications are huge!
As usual, more research is definitely needed.
One of my other shows, TestTube News has talked
a lot about gun violence and mass shootings
in
the past, so make sure you check that video
out here.
But on a happier note, NASA is about to fly-by
Pluto and we're doing a live Google Hangout
with our space producer Ian O'Neill and a
special guest INSIDE MISSION CONTROL.
It's going to be awesome.
Come join on July 14 at 1pm Pacific 4pm Eastern
and RSVP on the event page for a reminder!
There's a link in the description too!